So, let's think about what we want lookup to do. It's going
to take a hash table and a word, its output is going to
be the value associated with that keyword. What we want lookup to
do is, like add, first thing it has to do is find the
right bucket, and we've defined this
procedure hashtable_get_bucket to make it easy
to do that. Once we've found the bucket, what we want to do
for lookup is go through all the entries in that bucket. See
if there's one where the key of that entry matches the word that
we're passing in. So, your goals to define a procedure,
we call it hashtable_lookup. It takes two inputs, a hashtable,
and a key, which is the string, and it outputs the
value associated with that key. Whenever you're asked to define a
procedure, you should think carefully whether the description is clear enough.
In this case it's not. There's a situation that this description
doesn't cover. We need to think about the case where the
key is not actually in the table. What should we do
then? There's a lot of different things we could do. We
could produce an error. The problem with producing an error is then
we've got to deal with it when we call it. We'd like to, instead, produce the
value that we can use to represent the
case where there's no entry associated with that key.
And we'll use the None value for that. So, if the key is not in the
table, the result of lookup should be None,
which means there's no value associated with that key.